unia dont vendredi le 25e anniversaire
du référendum de 1995 ce que
l'indépendance du québec demeure encore
une option réaliste alors j'en discute
avec le nouveau chef du parti québécois
presse et pierre plamondon bonjour
monsieur st pierre plamondon
bonjour alors comment réagissez-vous
tout d'abord aux propos des bonbons des
chats la première moi je suis un grand
admirateur de yvon deschamps et j'avais
vu cette entrevue la dalle moi ça m'a
touché parce que yo dans le discours
devant des changes tout le paradoxe
québécois il ya une part de lui qui dira
c'est fini on arrivera pas puis on nous
parle de lui qui dit mais avec un
nouveau chef dans cinq ans et ont jamais
et je pense que c'est là que les
québécois se situe je pense qu'une
majorité de québécois forment ce qu'on
aurait dû devenir un pays à 95 et que
les choses seraient mieux aujourd'hui si
c'était le cas et en même temps est-ce
qu'on a la force qu'on a le courage de
vraiment régler cette question là d'un
meilleur avenir à nos enfants dans nos
propres pays
c'est la question de fond et les
passionnantes et il ya un sondage publié
hier qui nous démontre qu'en fait il ya
encore 40 % après répartition des 2,6 de
gens qu'ils voteraient oui demain matin
si beaucoup compte tenu du peu de place
qu'ont accordé à l'idée d'indépendance
surtout connu au cours des dernières
années sont dans la plupart des médias
présents après cette idée la communauté
dont les québécois ne veulent pas c'est
pour ça que les chefs nous disent
et quand j'entends yvon deschamps je me
dis bien il est le dilemme de fond des
québécois est ce qu'on a ce courage là
de régler la question une fois pour
toute notre guerrier et est-ce qu'on a
la force et c'est là qu'intervient le
parti québécois plus nouveau cycle qu'on
veut mettre en marché donc quand et des
yeux de l'ouvragé
ça vous en est bien conscient j'imagine
aux minéraux etc oui ça plaît rebâtir le
camp du oui le sujet publié ce livre là
en début de campagne tout le long de la
campagne
j à la direction du parti québécois j'ai
dit le soyons à naître on est à rebâtir
pour relancer ce parti là mais c'est un
privilège en même temps parce que si on
regarde depuis louis joseph papineau a
aujourd'hui c'est la quête de génération
en génération de rappeurs pour sa
liberté sa normalité dans une démocratie
normale viable donc il
quelque chose a terminé un destin
inachevé et qui est porté par yvon
deschamps qui vont être portés par
d'autres générations jusqu'à temps qu'on
un autre moment où on se joint au
concert des nations ont de vieux pays
qui rayonne à l'international
est-ce que ce destin sera porté par le
parti québécois rrq comme d'yvon
deschamps en fait c'est ce qu'il dit et
le parti a fait son temps et quand on
regarde on regarde quelques données neuf
députés à la chambre des communes
défaite historique en 2018 est imparti
caquistes qui rallie le plus grand
nombre de souverainistes
le pq cabu son membership diminué de
moitié en quelques années
donc c'est un parti qui doit travailler
fort pour pouvoir être celui qui va
porter serait parce que dans le fond les
souverainistes sont éparpillés entre
plusieurs partis en ce moment québec
solidaire la cac
le parti québécois exactement et c'est
l'opportunité l'espace de croissance
pour le parti québécois et un nouveau
chef qui s'est fait élire sur la base du
message de changement de reconstruire il
ya un gap le les sondages placent le
parti entre 16 et 18% 2 points derrière
seulement les libéraux il dit soit dit
en passant est avec une avance
confortable sur québec solidaire
mais il ya une grande un grand espace
ans que 40% l'indépendantiste les
intentions de vote en ce moment du parti
québécois
d'où l'intérêt pour le parti de
s'assumer et de parler d'avenir de
parler d'un projet de société qu'on
mérite et qui est nécessaire pour
assurer la viabilité linguistiques
culturelles et nous intérêts économiques
à moyen et à long terme
donc si on s'assume moi je pense que
l'espace de croissance pour le parti
québécois
il est grand et lorsque vous parlez des
sondages des difficultés du parti
québécois en fait on voit exactement les
mêmes tendances pour le parti libéral et
pour québec solidaire et ce sera le code
temps qu'on a une période de pandémie
par contre une fois la pandémie terminé
c'est surprenant ce qui peut arriver et
c'est ce qui rend les élections 2022 si
intéressante à mon avis oui
voir aussi que la caq mon prend soin de
goût et est un souverainiste convaincu
et la carte
et donc le premier ministre donc je
disais rallier le plus grand nombre de
souverainistes et et on voit que si on
regarde l'option souverainiste par
exemple donc les sondages aujourd'hui
indique que ce sont les plus vieux les
55 ans et plus qui croit encore les
jeunes boudent cette option lors qu en
il ya 25 ans c'était l'inversé donc
énormément de travail aux prêts à faire
auprès des jeunes
et peut-être que les nationalistes on
comprend que les nationalistes convaincu
aussi sur tout et plus confortables avec
un programme comme celui de la carte un
programme nationaliste à la défense des
intérêts du québec temporairement parce
que le programme nationaliste de la caq
nous démontre c'est qu'on n'obtient que
des refus à ottawa aussi spectaculaire
c'est et des refus accumulé les uns
après les autres et ce à un moment donné
on va obliger de faire le bilan de sa et
par rapport aux jeunes boudent et c'est
un très grand mot lorsqu'on pense
lorsqu'on parle de 31 % des jeunes qui
sont en faveur de l'option papa de
guider mais on part d'une opportunité
extraordinaire ou dans le cadre d'une
génération
il ya tout un groupe d'âge qui n'a pas
été partie à cette discussion là à qui
on n'a jamais donné la chance de
participer au débat sur l'avenir du
québec
donc c'est une opportunité pour le parti
québécois dans l'est plus dans les
générations plus âgées
mon hôte des jeux et des ballots les
gens sont peut-être plus camper mais par
rapport aux jeunes l'espace est très
grand et c'est un projet d'avenir qui
notamment sur le plan environnemental
sur le plan de nos intérêts économiques
sur le plan de notre place à
l'international
c'est le projet qui est extrêmement
enthousiasmant donc l'espace il est là
mon avis mais quand vous aviez une jeune
députée comme catherine fournier qui a
décidé de quitter le parti québécois et
devenir indépendante en disant que le
parti en fait ne reflétait plus la
bataille qu'elle souhaitait mener
justement pour l'indépendance coup dur
pour pour le parti un message qu'elle
envoie aussi aux jeunes ou peut-être que
c'est un message aussi qui représente
que les jeunes pensent non je pense pas
la preuve sur ma campagne
j'avais un appui vraiment extrêmement
grand chez les jeunes durant la course à
la direction du parti québécois est bon
évidemment il dans l'histoire de tous
partis il ya des mouvements par rapport
aux députés mais on est en phase de
reconstruction comme je l'aï dit il faut
repartir le camp du oui et déjà qu'ils
sont prêtes à rebâtir les gens qui sont
prêts à servir pour se
cause là il y en a et les nouvelles sont
bonnes en ce moment parti québécois dont
s'était mobilisé 7
cette opportunité l'homme et à ce moment
là l'humeur est très positive ici au
parti non en terminant on parle de ce
maître cinquième anniversaire vendredi
du du référendum de 95 vous avez déjà
dit que vous voulez faire du québec un
pays souverainiste et que le pq sous
votre leadership ne vise pas la gestion
ordinaire d'une progresse donc ça veut
dire que c'est le pq est élu avec vous à
sa tête et bien vous allez tenir un
référendum dans un premier mandat
définitivement et d'ailleurs ce que je
dis à la population c'est si vous êtes
d'accord avec le fait que le québec
doivent devenir un pays votez pour nous
contribué embarqués parce qu'il faut le
faire et on veut réussir
donc faut se placer dans une mentalité
de gens qui ont tout à gagner et qui
vise un objectif légitime c'est le
service de la liberté et de la justice
dont il est question pour tous les
québécois et je pense qu'il faut être
transparent s'assumer pleinement parce
que faut être fier du projet que l'on
porte et qui vont un jour avoir lu j'en
suis convaincu et en 2016 jean françois
lisée qui était chef du parti et lui
avait promis un premier mandat péquiste
sans référendum en disant que ça prenait
du temps pour organiser un référendum
jacques parizeau avait mis six ans pour
un organisme dont vous êtes plus pressé
que ça ou au risque de le perdre ce
nouveau référendum dans un premier
mandat
c'est le pq était de la mentalité c'est
pas le risque de perdre c'est qu'on a
tout à gagner dans ce projet là et si on
est porté au pouvoir c'est parce que on
aura fait le travail qu'on entreprend
maintenant et on aura cette majorité
l'appui dans le contexte un sondage à 40
% de québécois qui pensent que
l'indépendance est une bonne option
on parle dans une position qui est très
intéressante parce que on peut pas dire
que dans les dernières années on est mis
de l'avant cette question là de manière
aussi assumer quand ce moment donc les
prochaines années vont être excitante
intéressante à suivre
de ce point de vue merci beaucoup de
votre temps merci d'avoir été avec nous
que ce st-pierre plamondon mère facebook
où on voit